[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les
correspondances sur Public Sénat
aujourd'hui on vous parle de ces
solutions pour sauver la planète
applicable tout de suite pour peu que
les politiques s'en donnent les moyens
des innovations portées par nos PME nos
startups qui peuvent nous permettre non
pas dans 10 ans mais dès maintenant de
réduire notre consommation énergétique
et notre impact carbone le tout dans une
logique de rentabilité économique
bonjour Bertrand Picard bonjour de vous
avoir dans cette émission
on vous présente plus mais on fait quand
même vous êtes le premier homme à avoir
eu cette chance de faire le tour du
monde à bord d'un avion propulsé
uniquement l'énergie solaire le célèbre
solar RIM pulse c'est aussi la Fondation
votre fondation qui recense depuis 2003
les solutions techniques les plus
rentables les plus propres services de
l'environnement puis un nouveau combat
c'est votre combat actuel c'est cette
campagne donc de prête à voter que vous
avez lancé pour accélérer la transition
énergétique en France il y a vraiment
urgence en même temps quand on lit
dernier rapport du GIEC on se dit oui il
faut accélérer là alors il y a urgence
il y a beaucoup de problèmes une fois
que vous avez dit ça vous décourager
tout le monde parce que vous parce que
tout le monde a pensé que le problème
est trop gros pour qu'on puisse agir
donc moi j'ai essayé d'inverser la chose
et de parler davantage de solutions que
de problème et de montrer que on peut
répondre à l'urgence par le fait que des
solutions soient économiquement
rentables soit attrayantes soit
créatrice d'emploi soit enthousiasmante
alors on a cherché avec la Fondation
Solar Impulse combien il y en avait dans
le monde on en a trouvé jusqu'à
maintenant 1500
1486 et ces solutions sont à disposition
mais ne sont pas utilisées même si elles
sont économiquement rentables et on a
regardé pourquoi et on a pris en France
50 solutions qui auraient vraiment un
bénéfice magnifique pour des carboner et
on a demandé aux innovateurs ce qui les
bloquait et nous ont donné des
obstacles réglementaires des obstacles
législatifs etc ce fait qu'on a demandé
un cabinet d'avocat de tourner tous ces
problèmes en recommandation de
changement de législatif et on a sorti
ce prêt à voter c'est pas un livre
amusant à lire pour des noms
spécialistes mais c'est 5 autres
recommandations de législatives pour les
parlementaires de manière à débloquer
les obstacles qui jusqu'à maintenant
empêcher des solutions de se développer
donc vous les interpellez c'est
politique avec donc dans votre buzza
c'est 50 solutions appliquez tout de
suite j'insiste à 50 recommandations
et vous les êtes rencontrés manuel
Macron la Premier ministre madame borne
les députés les sénateurs Valérie
Pécresse président de la Région
Île-de-France vous êtes senti une marque
d'intérêt au minimum un intérêt fort
voire plus parce qu'on se dit ils vous
ont reçu parce que vous êtes Bertrand
Picard et que pour leur image c'est bon
de s'afficher avec vous quelle est la
sincérité dans leur démarche alors vous
savez je m'attendais à être très bien
reçu par les écologistes et par la
gauche en disant voilà on va pouvoir
pousser des solutions sur le plan
législatif et en fait qui se sont le
plus intéressés ces centres droites et
droites c'est les républicains c'est
Renaissance c'est à ce niveau là et je
m'attendais pas à ce que ce soit eux qui
poussent autant les solutions
Valérie Pécresse s'est arrangé pour qui
est 5 amendements déposés à la loi au
projet de loi sur l'énergie en prenant 5
recommandations du prêt à voter donc en
fait il y a eu beaucoup d'intérêts mais
ça venait pas forcément d'où je pensais
et je n'ai pas encore eu l'occasion
d'être auditionné par la gauche par les
écologistes
sur les commissions des autres parties
qui m'ont auditionné c'est assez curieux
mais enfin c'est comme ça on peut faire
déjà Bertrand Picard un petit bilan
peut-être tiens sur la région
Île-de-France on se dit quoi vous avez
proposé les les datacenter des solutions
une solution pour rendre les Data Center
plus propre elle a pas été retenue je
crois cette proposition non mais
regardez c'est c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment étonnant il y a bon il y a
des recommandations qui ont été
intégrées c'est la grivevoltaïsme et le
solaire flottant ça c'est dans le dans
le projet de loi dans le projet de loi
non mais on demande non non alors à la
région c'est clair que ça va être
utilisé Valérie Pécresse et passionné
par ces solutions Jean rotner à la
région Grand Est également mais il y a
eu des amendements qui ont été amenés au
Parlement pour que certaines de ces
recommandations puissent intégrer la loi
notamment que la chaleur des Data Center
puisse être utilisée pour chauffer des
villes et que les émanations de méthane
des décharges publics puissent être
récupérées pour être réutilisé comme
énergie à la place du gaz russe
c'est quand même extraordinaire de voir
que ces deux amendements ont été refusés
parce que
les arguments c'est de toute façon on
veut diminuer les décharges publics donc
on va pas récupérer le méthane des
décharges publics je vois pas le rapport
l'autre amendement sur les Data Center a
été refusé parce que le but est d'avoir
des Data Center qui chauffent moins mais
il y a quand même la chaleur à récupérer
donc en fait il y a une logique dans le
monde politique qui m'échappe clairement
on amène des solutions qui sont
économiquement rentables qui peuvent
tout de suite entrer en fonction qui
sont crédibles qui créent des emplois
qui améliorent la qualité de vie et puis
on les retient pas pourquoi c'est
blocages alors parce que pour arriver à
débloquer quelque chose il y a beaucoup
de règles administratives à changer de
règle bureaucratique à changer et je
vais vous dire une chose il y a quand
même pas mal de gens qui pensent que
c'est plus simple de rien changer que de
changer quelque chose que c'est plus
facile et je pense que ce qui va
détruire la planète c'est pas non
seulement la pollution c'est la paresse
et la paralysie et la complaisance on
croit qu'on fait des mobilismes et on
fait absolument pas assez
quels sont les propositions qui ont été
retenues Bertrand Picard notamment dans
ce dans le projet de loi dans la loi
désormais sur les énergies renouvelables
il y a eu l'installation des panneaux
solaires flottants oui ça ça a été
retenu ou ça ça a été retenu et
heureusement parce que vous avez une
entreprise comme accuoénergique est une
entreprise française qui a mis à peu
près 10 ans pour installer des panneaux
solaires flottants sur la carte
artificiel à l'acte de carrière en fait
dans le Vaucluse
10 ans pour ça vous savez les énergies
renouvelables c'est pas que du solaire
et du vent
c'est aussi d'hydroélectrique de petites
rivières c'est mettre dans des rivières
des des petites turbines entraînées par
l'eau qui produisent de l'électricité
pour un village et ça c'est pas un
problème pour les poissons parce qu'on
prend pas toute la rivière c'est aussi
la géothermie c'est pouvoir brancher des
pompes à chaleur sur des puits
géothermiques à 180 mètres de profondeur
ça aussi il faut des facilités
administratives parce que sinon on
arrive rien à bouger on avance pas et
donc ces solutions qui auraient mérité
d'être intégrées pour le coup
à cette à cette loi ce projet de loi sur
les anneauxbles ça a pas été le cas vous
êtes déçu oui parce que cette loi est
fragmentaire elle est lacunaire il faut
vous savez ça sert à rien de vouloir
produire plus d'énergie même
renouvelable tant qu'on continue à
gaspiller l'énergie avec des systèmes
qui sont complètement inefficients avec
des lampadaires d'éclairage public qui
ont même pas d'ampoule LED et des choses
comme ça aujourd'hui si vous mettiez des
ampoules LED
partout où il n'y en a pas encore en
France ça équivaudrait à la production
énergétique de quatre centrales
nucléaires
c'est l'énergie qu'il faut pour faire
rouler 7 millions de voitures
électriques pourquoi ça n'a pas été
accepté ça
à voter
je sais pas demandé leur invité leur
invité les pots
vous allez les voir les députés les
sénateurs
certains sont très intéressants à
comprendre encore une fois le blocage
ils nous disent que c'est une initiative
de démocratie participative qu'ils
aiment beaucoup ça qui qu'on va aller
faire de des auditions avec toutes les
commissions avec davantage de
parlementaires etc puis on attend puis
on attend puis on demande des
invitations par les parler alors c'est
50 solutions elles ont été retenues
parmi donc on a dit les 1450 labellisés
par la Fondation solar in pulse pour
protéger l'environnement elles sont
applicables réplicables à l'échelle
nationale elles sont rentables et
exemple vous allez voir avec deux
innovations on est dans les
[Musique]